he shuffled into courts as he has for
the past two months
but what Harvey Weinstein didn't know
was that he wouldn't be walking out
again although he was acquitted of the
two most serious charges his convictions
for rape and sexual assault meant he was
handcuffed and sent to jail pending
sentencing guilty of forcing oral sex on
Miriam Haley a young production
assistant guilty of raping aspiring
actress Jessica man in total 8 women
testified against Weinstein Weinstein is
a vicious serial sexual predator who
used his power to threaten rape assault
trick humiliate and silences victims for
decades he was the toast of Hollywood
but his career had already ended in
disgrace forced to quit his job by the
sheer weight of accusations against him
inside courtroom 99 victim's waived
their anonymity to be questioned and
cross-examined about the intimate
details of their sexual encounters with
Weinstein Mimi Haley said he was coming
toward me physically and I was backed
into a bedroom that was on the corner of
that open space area she said I walked
backwards because he was pushing me with
his body until I got to the bed and I
fell backwards onto the bed and I tried
to get up and he pushed me down she
continued I just said no no I don't want
this to happen
Jessica Mann defended continuing to have
contact with the movie producer I know
the history of my relationship with him
I know it was complicated and difficult
but that doesn't change the fact that he
raped me but his lawyer a Donner eterno
told the jury you don't have to like mr.
Weinstein this is not a popularity
contest but you have to remember that we
are not here to criminalize morality one
of his lawyers told me about Weinstein's
reaction to the verdicts you handle it
like a stoic gentleman he just kept
repeating but I'm innocent but I'm
innocent I'm a minute I'm innocent how
could this happen in America but will
will he'll have a very powerful appeal
he didn't get convicted of the top count
we could go in and get him bail pending
appeal and hopefully he'll be home with
the challenge for prosecutors was to
explain to the jury why women hadn't
reported allegations to the police at
the time they happened the prosecution
knows the holes in their case in terms
of the gaps in the time between the
assault and how long it took for some of
these victims to come forward and so
they've plugged those holes with expert
witnesses who were very good who were
used in the Bill Cosby case and as a
result of that they were able to make
out a case where a jury can connect
those dots women who had made similar
accusations some of whom are now suing
Weinstein had come to court when the
trial got underway to make their
presence felt the survivors group issued
a statement while it's disappointing
that today's outcome does not deliver
the true full justice that so many women
deserve Harvey Weinstein will now
forever be known as a convicted serial
predator this conviction would not be
possible without the testimony of the
courageous women and the many women who
have spoken out these were just a few of
the many allegations against Harvey
Weinstein prosecutors chose the ones
they thought stood the best chance of
winning a conviction but the stories
triggered a much wider response from
women who said that Harvey Weinstein was
just one man among many who'd abused
their power for sexual gratification
Weinstein will be sentenced on March the
11th he faces a minimum of five years in
jail and a maximum of 25 years in woods
Sky News New York